From sitcom titans to Oscar nominees and the
character actors in between, these are the
people behind All in the Family who have sadly
passed away since their time visiting the Bunker household.
Before playing Archie Bunker, Carroll O'Connor
started his acting career on the stage in
Dublin, Ireland, and his native New York City.
After making his TV debut on Sunday Showcase,
he went on to appear on the likes of Gunsmoke,
Bonanza, and The Outer Limits, among others.
But O'Connor's most successful role was of
course Archie, whom he played on both All
in the Family and the spinoff Archie Bunker's
Place.
After his time as the Bunker patriarch came
to an end, O'Connor went on to star on the
TV version of In the Heat of the Night.
He also became one of a select few to win
Primetime Emmys in both the comedy and drama categories.
Offscreen, O'Connor and his wife Nancy Fields
had an adopted son named Hugh, who died by
suicide in 1995 after a long struggle with
addiction.
That inspired his father to do a number of
public service announcements in the 90s for
Partnership for a Drug Free America.
"Get between your kids and drugs any way you
can."
O'Connor died in 2001 at the age of 76 from
a heart attack and complications of diabetes.
As Edith Bunker, Jean Stapleton was kind and
understanding, though she also had to endure
the constant ridicule of her husband.
Nevertheless, Edith was the heart of All in
the Family, and there were times when she
would prove Archie wrong and help him find
his empathy.
Like Carroll O'Connor, Stapleton was also
born in New York City and also started out
on the stage.
As the daughter of an opera singer, the performing
arts were in her blood.
She eventually made it to Broadway as part
of famous musicals like Funny Girl and Damn Yankees.
Stapleton's pre-All in the Family TV credits
includes the likes of The Patty Duke Show,
My Three Sons, and Dennis the Menace.
She only appeared on five episodes of the
spinoff Archie Bunker's Place, and the decision
was then made to have Edith die from a stroke.
"It wasn't supposed to be like this, you know."
Stapleton herself died in 2013 at the age
of 90 after a long and extensive career.
Sherman Hemsley played George Jefferson, who
proved to be popular enough to become the
lead on his own spinoff show, The Jeffersons.
On All in the Family, George was Archie Bunker's
neighbor whom he often butted heads with.
As The Jeffersons theme song made famous,
George and his family moved on up from their
former neighborhood in Queens to a deluxe
apartment in the sky in Manhattan.
The Jeffersons ran for a whopping 11 seasons
from 1975 through 1985.
Hemsley also enjoyed an extensive stage career
and appeared on other TV shows, like Dinosaurs
and The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air.
When Hemsley died in 2012 at the age of 74
from lung cancer, his will left everything
to a woman named Flora, his dear friend and
business partner.
Hemsley wasn't buried for over a month after
his death, because a Philadelphia man named
Richard Thornton claimed to be his long-lost
brother.
The drawn-out legal proceedings were eventually
resolved when the court ruled in Flora's favor.
Isabel Sanford played George Jefferson's wife
Louise, who was lovingly known as "Weezy."
Whereas Archie and George were hot-headed
and frequently sparring, Edith and Louise
were always trying to figure out how to calm
their husbands down.
Isabel is portrayed as kind and sensible like
Edith, though much sharper.
Sanford was born in New York City and joined
Harlem's American Negro Theater and The Star
Players after graduating from high school.
She made her stage debut in 1946, as she appeared
in both Broadway and off-Broadway productions.
In 1960, after separating from her husband,
she and her three children moved to Los Angeles,
where her movie and TV career really kicked
off.
After appearing in the 1967 film Guess Who's
Coming to Dinner, she caught the attention
of Norman Lear, who then cast her on All in
the Family.
"I got something to say to you, boy.
Just exactly what you're trying to pull here."
During her time on The Jeffersons, Sanford
earned five Golden Globe and seven Emmy nominations.
When she won an Emmy in 1981 for outstanding
lead actress in a comedy series, she became
the first Black actress to triumph in that
category.
She died in 2004 in Los Angeles at the age
of 86.
George and Louise Jefferson's son Lionel initially
appeared on the first episode of All in the
Family's first season, "Meet the Bunkers."
Lionel is notable for being a positive depiction
of an opinionated Black man, which was rather
revolutionary for the time.
Lionel doesn't let Archie's casual racism
bother him, as he instead laughs it off as
a sign of his neighbor's backwards thinking.
He sees Archie as more ignorant than evil,
and often patronizes him.
Still, Archie considers Lionel a friend and
even something of a mentee.
"What are friends for, Lionel?"
Lionel was played by Mike Evans on both All
in the Family and The Jeffersons.
During the first few seasons of the latter,
he marries his biracial wife Jenny, and they
have a daughter named Jessica.
Evans eventually left The Jeffersons to work
on the sitcom Good Times, which he helped create.
He was replaced on The Jeffersons by Damon
Evans, who was not related to Mike despite
their shared last name.
Mike Evans returned for the final season of
The Jeffersons and died of throat cancer at
the age of 57 in 2006.
Allan Melvin played Archie's neighbor and
best friend Barney Hefner.
Before he played Barney, though, he showed
up in the Season 2 episode "Archie in the
Lock-Up" as a desk officer at a police precinct.
Melvin's popularity rose during his time as
Barney, and he ended up becoming a series
regular on all four seasons of the spinoff
Archie Bunker's Place.
Born in Kansas City, Missouri, Melvin had
the sort of expressive face that TV was invented for.
He appeared on such classic sitcoms as Gomer
Pyle, The Dick Van Dyke Show, The Andy Griffith
Show, and My Favorite Martian.
He also famously played Sam the Butcher, Alice's
boyfriend, on The Brady Bunch.
Melvin died in 2008 from cancer at the age
of 84, and he just so happens to be buried
near Carroll O'Connor.
Betty Garrett and Vincent Gardenia played
the Bunkers' liberal Catholic neighbors Irene
and Frank Lorenzo.
Irene is Irish, while Frank is Italian, thus
highlighting the multicultural makeup of their
Queens neighborhood.
Irene is also something of a feminist for
the day.
She's handy with tools, and she often fixes
things around her own house, as well as the Bunkers'.
Archie even gets her a job as a forklift operator
at the same plant where he works.
"I got the job!"
"Oh!"
Another Missouri native, Garrett appeared
on Broadway in the 1940s and had a contract
with MGM during Hollywood's studio era.
Her most notable TV role other than Irene
was the landlady Edna on Laverne & Shirley.
Garrett won a Golden Globe for her portrayal
of Irene, though the character was phased
out of the show in later seasons.
Garrett's TV career continued on such shows
as The Golden Girls and Murder, She Wrote.
She continued acting into the early 2000s
on the likes of Grey's Anatomy and Boston Public.
She died in 2011 at the age of 91 of an aortic
aneurysm.
Vincent Gardenia played Frank Lorenzo as a
boisterous fellow who loves to sing and cook.
He once worked as a salesman, though what
he sold is never actually mentioned.
Before he was Fank, Gardenia appeared on an
earlier episode of All in the Family as the
man who sells his house to the Jeffersons,
and he also played a swinger in a Season 3 episode.
Gardenia was born in Naples, Italy in 1920.
During the course of his long and varied acting
career, he was nominated for two Academy Awards,
for 1973's Bang the Drum Slowly and 1987's
Moonstruck.
When Gardenia died in 1992 at the age of 72,
it led to quite the theatrical conundrum.
He was in Philadelphia to perform on stage
in the comedy Breaking Legs.
He originated the role off-Broadway the year
before.
On the morning of the final preview show,
it was discovered that he'd died of a heart
attack in his hotel room.
The show went on, though, with the opening
performance dedicated to his memory.
George Jefferson's brother Henry was played
by Mel Stewart, an actor, director, and musician.
He was introduced along with Louise and Lionel
before Sherman Hemsley joined the cast as George.
Henry and George only appear in one episode
together on All in the Family, which focuses
on Henry's going-away party for his move to
Chicago.
The move was a way of phasing out the character,
who never appeared on The Jeffersons.
"I want to thank you, Bunker, for letting
me know and letting me see that some white
folks are better than other white folks."
Though Henry was only a bit player on All
in the Family, Stewart enjoyed an extensive TV career.
His next project after All in the Family was
Roll Out, a short-lived series about Black
soldiers during World War II.
He also appeared on such shows as Good Times,
The Love Boat, and The Golden Girls.
His last onscreen role was the 1993 movie
Made in America.
He died in 2002 from Alzheimer's disease at
the age of 72.
Bea Arthur played Edith's feminist cousin
Maude, who went on to have her own eponymous spinoff.
Maude and Archie often butted heads, and unlike
Lionel Jefferson, who let Archie's ignorance
slide with a quip, Maude was famous for fighting
back.
"You're fat."
Maude appeared on one episode of All in the
Family Season 1, and then one more episode
in Season 2, which served as a backdoor pilot
for her own show.
Born in 1922 in Brooklyn, Arthur started her
career on the stage.
She won a Tony in 1966 for best featured actress
in a musical for Mame.
After Maude, she landed another iconic role
as Dorothy on The Golden Girls.
She continued acting into the 2000s, appearing
on such shows as Malcolm in the Middle and
Curb Your Enthusiasm.
She even returned to Broadway for a 2002 production
called Bea Arthur on Broadway: Just Between Friends.
She died in 2009 from lung cancer at the age
of 86.
Bob Hastings played Archie's friend Tommy
Kelsey, the owner of the bar that the Bunker
patriarch frequents.
As the place where Archie can go to relax
and have a drink, it's basically his home
away from home, so much so that when Tommy
puts it up for sale, Archie mortgages his
own house to buy it.
This catalyzes the transition from All in
the Family to the spinoff Archie Bunker's Place.
The Brooklyn-born Hastings started his acting
career on the radio, where he played Archie
Andrews in a 1945 show based on Archie Comics.
He transitioned to TV soon after and showed
up on the likes of Hogan's Heroes, Green Acres,
and McHale's Navy.
From 1978 to 1986, he played Captain Ramsey
on the daytime soap opera General Hospital.
In the 90s, he turned to voice acting, which
included the part of Commissioner Gordon on
Batman: The Animated Series, among other roles
in the DC Animated Universe.
Hastings died in 2014 from prostate cancer
at the age of 89.
Though he never actually acted on All in the
Family, creator and executive producer Norman
Lear was obviously indispensable to the show.
You could even go a step further and say that
he was essential to an entire era of TV.
In addition to All in the Family, he helped
dream up The Jeffersons and Maude, and he
executive produced One Day at a Time, Sanford
and Son, Good Times, and Mary Hartman.
At one point, he was responsible for three
of the four top-rated TV shows in the country.
Lear caught his big break back in the 1950s
penning jokes for Dean Martin and Jerry Lewis.
Younger viewers might be more familiar with
the times that he collaborated with All in
the Family star Rob Reiner, who's gone on
to have a steady directing career.
Lear had a hand in Reiner's classic films
This is Spinal Tap, Stand by Me, and The Princess Bride.
The Oscar-nominated, multiple Emmy-winning
Lear passed away on December 5, 2023 at the
age of 101.